Michelle visage 14 Emmy nominations for
RuPaul's Drag Race this year can you
imagine it's an honor and I don't know
what's gonna happen but we are so
grateful for it season 12 of drag race
is approaching
they'll be that your 10th season right
yes because I started season 3 I want to
take a trip down memory lane we pulled
your very first episode of drag racing
right ok I want you to watch it back and
then we'll talk about it but a long time
the return of Michelle visage episodes
wouldn't keep us apart I'm working with
a paper material that was new for me
here's the thing you bring out a big
giant snowman the Snowman was bigger
than the payoff and the thing about
props you never want to be upstaged by a
paper mache snowman you know what I'm
saying you don't how long has it been
since you watch that a long time I
haven't gone back to season 3 in a long
time but I actually appreciate it
because I fought hard to get onto the
show to get out of a job that I was
doing it was a whole mishegoss to get
there but then when I got there I was
really excited as you could tell it's
ready
very very chatty I was gonna say I was
when I went and pulled that I was like I
don't know how much her judging style
has changed not much I was told to step
my drag up and that's what I wanted to
do so tell me why you're out here in a
bathing suit with no corset and a belt I
think I am Who I am you know I think
that some Queens have confronted me and
said you know I you're very harsh and I
know I wasn't expecting that and it
hurts more than you think it does and if
anybody that knows me or watches the
show they know that my intentions it's
all about your intentions my intentions
are never ill they're always pure if we
were all Paula Abdul you'd get bored
really quickly I think we all need to
take a moment to talk about the bravest
struggle of all coming out here I'm
telling us about her struggle a struggle
with not wearing hip not wearing hip
heads oh my god now we're a decade into
your journey on drag race I want to run
through some of your favorite and least
favorite moments in your time on Jack
okay do you have a favorite lip-synch
for your life
of all time you know it's really
difficult because there's so many great
ones I know Latrice and
Kenya Michaels natural woman was a good
one Ritz Neptune Natalie Cole lip-sync
Delta and Manila MacArthur Park police
and Tatiana
[Music]
there's a whole bunch oh yeah great ones
and I guess the least favorite one would
be the dachshund Layla do you have a
favorite runway look of all time
anything RuPaul wears because and I know
it sounds like a suck-up but it's honest
to God when root comes out every time
it's breathtaking and sometimes she'll
say oh this I've had this for four or
five years I just couldn't figure out
where to wear it and it's like there's
nothing wrong with I wouldn't change a
thing like if I were judging her there's
nothing I would change do you have a
runway look that you're like never want
to see that again well there's there's a
few usually for me it starts with the
shoes because there's a lot of times
girls feel comfortable in certain clunky
chunky not cute shoes
they say grandma Hills you know they
could have a great outfit and then you
go dip it down and you just like down at
the bottom of the feet and it's like you
just ruined everything you worked so
hard for oh right did you have a
favorite gag or kind of run away
surprised that's happened drag race has
turned into a reveal show yes which is
amazing and I think the Brooklyn Heights
reveal when she pulled that at the Afro
often - that long blonde wig was like oh
my god that was amazing but Roxy did it
first so we can't forget Roxy after she
told us that heart-wrenching story of
how she was left at the bus stop my
mother left my sister and myself at a
bus stop when I was three I try to stay
so strong and then proceeded to wipe the
floor oh yeah with what my hair back and
forth in the first we've revealed Bru
and I listen I've been around drag queen
since I'm 17 years old and I'm 50
Andrews been around in her whole life
she created it and we have not seen it
like that before you're the two of you
talk reactions in that moment like
you're like yeah living for the moment
Andrew I think those the first slackjaw
ever saw room gagging
all time that's my number one moment on
this show my number one moment is the
first time I got to sit in that chair
next to real people ask me all the time
what my favorite season was and I really
it's like a gay Sophie's Choice I can't
pick a favorite Queen besides a rue and
I can't pick a favorite season
I think season 3 will always be special
to me because that's where I was able to
finally commence you know Andrew looked
at me and said now the show begins and I
think for a lot of the viewers that's
the season where the show began - well
thank you right I think it started to
find its footing I think you're right
it's I don't I don't take the credit for
that I think season 3 was monumental I
think you know just that that top three
that we had and the journey and then
season four is where it kicked into high
gear it was like there's a puzzle a
couple missing pieces fell into place
that year and it's been taking off ever
since
[Music]